hello my name is Carl dice Roth I'm a
professor of bioengineering and
psychiatry at Stanford and the Howard
Hughes Medical Institute and today I'd
like to tell you a little bit about
optogenetics
some of the humble origins of this
method in science some of its
applications and some of the interesting
lessons that it teaches us about the
process of biology
now I'm also a psychiatrist and a lot of
the inspiration for this technology came
from psychiatry and although this is an
important field of medicine it's got a
long way to go in many ways we haven't
progressed too far in our basic
description of the core symptoms and
their underpinnings their causal
underpinnings then we had a hundreds of
years ago here's a depiction of some of
the earliest medical model type
descriptions of depression and this
symptom that today we call anhedonia the
inability to enjoy normally rewarding
things and john holliman the early 1800s
described in melancholy what we would
call depression today they therefore
neglect those objects and pursuits which
formerly proved sources of delight and
instruction and this is about as precise
as we can be today about what anhedonia
really is in in psychiatry and what's a
really amazing part of the story is
microbial organisms single-celled forms
of life have given us tools that in the
last few years have allowed us to come
to a deeper understanding of this
fundamental and important medical and
scientific question and many others like
it now this also gives an opportunity to
take a broader view about what is
optogenetics where does it stand in the
broader context of interventions of
experiments that we can do in
neuroscience and in the brain which as
we all know is a very complicated system
with many interconnecting parts we have
historically had the ability to use
either magnetic or electrical
interventions to
stimulate neurons but one problem is
that they cannot discriminate individual
kinds of neurons that may be right next
to each other they all look the same to
an electrical or magnetic intervention
what optogenetics allows us to do is to
put particular sensitizers antennas of a
sort for external sources of energy
information into specific kinds of
neurons and then we can use light in
this case if we make light-sensitive
antennas or transducers and make neurons
of a particular kind respond to light
and we do that to allow different kinds
of ions to flow into cells and turn
neurons on or off depending on the
experiment that's the fundamental idea
of optic genetics and it's something
people have wanted to do for a very long
time the first person who seemed to have
framed that the possible solution to
this age-old question was Francis Crick
in 1999 he described the essence of this
problem that we needed to control turn
on or off individual kinds of cells and
he suggested the ideal signal would be
light he didn't have an idea of how to
do it but in his usual perceptive
fashion he had some pretty good
instincts I would say and what I like to
do here is to to sort of pay homage to
the many people who have thought about
this and done experiments and and
contributed both historically and up to
the present in making all of this
ultimately work now there were early
efforts dating back to 2002 a pioneer in
this field geremy's and Bach was able to
take individual components from a
metazoan i.e multicellular organisms we
all know of course we have
light-sensitive cells and our retinas
and they achieve light sensitivity with
a cascade of proteins and he was able to
get to the point where he could bring
some of those individual components of
that cascade together and confer light
sensitivity on neurons and the bright
areas of this plot are where the light
was on and there were other groups who
also took what you might call a
multi-component approach to try to make
neurons light-sensitive now the only
thing that held back these el
again methods was in many ways their
multi-component see which contributed to
difficulties in targeting and they of
course would be the first state and in
fact showed beautifully that there was
some delay in the onset of the
responsility the action potentials that
were fired by the cells in response to
the light and what allowed this field to
take off was the microbial approach as I
alluded to earlier now these microbial
organisms they're small they don't have
a lot of space to work with nor do they
have to do as complex processing as
other organisms do and so they add the
leeway evolutionarily it seems to make
very efficient all in one single
component systems for both detecting
light and generating ion flow and that
allowed the generalizable aspect of this
solution to happen and this is a field
that has its roots back even as far back
as the early 1970s Diderot stirrer held
and Walter stickiness in 1971 identified
bacteria rhodopsin and over decades they
and a thriving community of researchers
were able to sort out how this amazing
protein works how it responds to light
how its photo cycle of the individual
protein allows ions to be transported
across the membrane and this pump type
class of microbial opsins bacteria
Dobson being an example was followed by
discovery of halorhodopsin x' where
instead of protons being moved chloride
ions are moved instead Peter hegemon and
his colleagues beginning with some early
predictive work in 1985 leading to a
very important paper in 2002 showed that
there were also channel type microbial
opsins that opened actual pores in the
membrane instead of pumping one ion at a
time and then many groups here Fang
Zhang in my laboratory was able to find
a red light activated channelrhodopsin
in 2008 and a great number of different
groups Fong Jung Peter Hegeman our
colleague at Boyden Garrick Naugle it's
bambor John's food itch and many others
have been identifying amazing amazingly
diverse
a microbial opsins with different
properties from across the phylogenetic
spectrum now what is striking is you'll
notice from this is how long we've known
about these and this happens to be my
biochemistry textbook the beautiful book
written by lewbert's Dreyer in 1988 this
was the version I used and and you can
see this is textbook type knowledge
description of the photo cycle of
bacteria Dobson for example part of the
foundational knowledge of biochemists
and neurobiologists now there were
people who did try to put these
microbial opsins in different settings
in fact successfully this is a very
interesting paper from 1994 where the
bacteria Dobson was indeed transferred
along with light-sensitive flow of ions
into a eukaryotic organism but nobody
had yet tried to actually create a tool
for neurobiology to turn on or turn off
individual kinds of cells neurons are
complicated they're vulnerable they're
sensitive they're different but in
principle it was an experiment that
could be done and there were indeed many
people trying to do it now the path to
this in my own lab started very near to
the time when I had started setting up
my independent laboratory and I had a
very humble approach where as you can
see I used very simple tallies to assess
how the experiments were working and
it's interesting to look back on the
simplicity of this early experiment but
what I was doing here
I had a broader view in the lab to try
different kinds of proteins to see if we
could turn neurons on or off with
different kinds of stimuli I had
acquired the channelrhodopsin gene I'd
written to the group in Germany that had
worked on the initial clone from Gehrig
Nagaland he sent me the clone right away
which was a very generous of him I was
also looking at different kinds of
potassium channels to see if we could
turn neurons on or off constitutively
active or dominant negative
aciem channels and I was putting all
these into separate groups of neurons
and culture to see if I could get
control over their activity level and I
was using a very simple straightforward
readout of membrane depolarization the
phosphorylation of a transcription
factor called CREB which I had done a
lot of work on previously and the
amazing result was that in these neurons
you can see by the red stain of the
nucleus of the cell and stimulated
compared to a unstimulated neuron both
of these were expressing the
channelrhodopsin coupled to a yellow
fluorescent protein so i could see a
number of things here i could see that
the gene that i'd put in was being
expressed it was being transported to
the membrane that the neuron was healthy
it hadn't exploded as a result of
putting this high levels of this
membrane protein into the cell which can
happen to be sure and moreover that the
light activated the light treated a
neuron revealed that it had been
stimulated this membrane had been
depolarized at calcium flux had occurred
and at and this biochemical readout was
telling us that this was happening and
in neurons that were expressing a lot of
the channelrhodopsin i could see a big
difference in the number of cells that
were reporting on this depolarization
event and overall it was Justice Scalia
significant and although this was a very
simple cheap humble experiment this
showed us that it was possible and this
was in early July of 2004 but things
went very quickly after that this is
what our small group looked like at the
time you can see the two grad students
hyung joong and ed Boyden here both now
at MIT Fong Jeong now also very well
known for his work on not CRISPR cast 9
systems but we knew that we had to do a
lot more than just show some neurons
getting stimulated we had to show this
was unique that it was potentially
generalizable or versatile that I could
potentially be applied in broader
systems and there was rightly so a lot
of skepticism at the time but the
students uh work did some really a
brilliant and creative work Fung Jong
design
the viral systems that would allow us to
put the channelrhodopsin in a very
versatile way into different brain
regions in vivo and the fact that it's
just a single gene allowed us to be
confident that this would work well
Edie did a number of beautiful
recordings showing how fast the
responses could be which was another
important feature of the system both its
potential generalizability and its speed
and there were many other groups working
on this at the time
Stephan her let's ajapa pan Yaya Woo's
group in Japan but we were able to put
the different pieces together in time to
get the paper out and it was published
that together with the two students at
and fung as well as garrett Nagaland
hertz bamberg and this though was I
wouldn't even say this was yet fully
optogenetics because there was a great
deal more work that needed to happen it
took about five more years of a very
intense effort to show that we had
actually created something that was
generalizable useful and broadly
applicable which was the key goal so
optogenetics didn't start overnight the
experiments were humble and simple but
it took a number of years to actually
say we had finally discovered how to
make this work part of the problem was
how do you get light into big mammalian
brains and this is an early sketch of
Hong Kong where he designed the
fiber-optic interface and this was from
2006 but then this looks very much like
how we now do it today so you can see
he's a good artist as well as a great
scientist and this fiber-optic interface
has since allowed us to do many things
but I'll show you one other first
experiment this was 2 years later in
2007 Oh Fung I was working with some
mice that we had made in collaboration
with pulping Fang and George Augustin
and these were mice designed to have
channelrhodopsin expressed in in the
brain and what Fung did was he implanted
into this mouse a fiberoptic on the
right side of its brain which as you
know will control movement toward or
attention to the left side of the world
and when he turned on the light
you'll see here the animal immediately
starts moving and starts turning to the
left and this was the moment when I
would say we finally knew that we had
made something that was going to be
broadly applicable generalizable and
that was followed quickly by a
collaborative set of experiments with
least a messiah
Alexei Robin ISA Antoinette Amman TDS
and others where we applied this
fiber-optic interface to target a deep
structure in the brain in the lateral
hypothalamus fun design some promoters
that would fit into a lentivirus and
allow us to control just one kind of
cell deep in the hypothalamus and in
this work we were able to play in
certain kinds of activity and show some
of the neural codes that were causal in
sleep-wake transitions and then even
then though this required you know some
very specific fragment of a promoter the
hypocretin promoter which would fit into
a virus and there was still rightly so
some skepticism as to how broadly
generalizable this would be but between
2009 and 2010 we finally were able to
show that there were a broad array of
different tools you could use to
generalize ibly target different kinds
of cells and by this point I would say
by 2010 or so people were able to see
that this could be applied to virtually
any system a good example of how that
all worked was in our studies of anxiety
now anxiety is a normal part of life
it's a healthy part of life of course it
can become excessive and it can be a
pathological in some cases but what we
were able to do is to use optogenetics
to play in patterns of activity or
suppress patterns of activity in
particular cells and projections in and
around structures relating to the
basolateral amygdala and the bed nucleus
of the stria terminalis
and the way we did some of these
experiments is we injected a virus and
adeno-associated virus into the
structure of interest the BNs T but then
we were able to position our fiber
optics in other downstream structures
and by doing so we were able to recruit
cells
defined by having a particular
projection pattern which as you can see
is a generalizable strategy you don't
need a special kind of animal or a
special promoter you just need to know
your Anatomy and this works because the
options are trafficked down the axons of
the cells particularly if we help them
out with little trafficking motifs that
were discovered in the lab by Vivian and
Grodd and ro and her colleagues and I'll
go I'll show you an example of how this
sort of thing works this is an
experiment I'll play this movie Kate I
in the lab did this work which I was
published in 2011 this is a what's
called an elevated plus maze the
so-called closed arm has these elevated
walls and you'll see that the animal
prefers to spend its time in the closed
arm of the maze very rarely venturing
out into the open arm which is like
walking the plank for an animal but in
our studies of anxiety related behaviors
what we found and what Kay was able to
show and we followed this up with a
great deal of other work was that there
were anti-anxiety pathways buried within
the brain when the blue letters come on
here you'll see when she started driving
one of these as we discovered
anti-anxiety pathways and you'll see for
the first time the mouse is willing to
go out into the open arms and explore
them which it never had been before
nothing else changed about the animal
the speed or anything else it simply was
willing to accept this risk and this was
instantaneously reversible and this of
course is only one feature of anxiety
apprehension in the absence of immediate
threat but there are other features too
respiratory rate changes subjective
feeling anxiety feels bad and resolution
of anxiety feels good and in later work
we were able to show that different
projections coming from the bed nucleus
of the street terminalis recruit
different features of anxiety using this
projection targeting approach where we
position the fiber-optic in a different
location than the injection of the virus
and this sort of thing allowed the
generalizability of optogenetics to
become clear and so in this sort of work
if you think back to those very early
humble experiments in culture you can
see
took a number of years to finally put
all the pieces together I'm often asked
what's the potential clinical impact of
a optogenetics although I'm a
psychiatrist I run a purely basic
science laboratory I'm not working on
clinical translation in my lab but it's
a natural question to ask and other
people are working on it the group of
antonella bond she found in 2013 that
they could turn down cocaine seeking
behavior in rats with optogenetic
stimulation of the medial prefrontal
cortex a very striking result that they
published in 2013 and that was then
followed up with a antibody and some
clinical colleagues with a opto
genetically guided clinical intervention
they used transcranial magnetic
stimulation which can be non-invasively
delivered to awake human beings of
course human brains are a lot bigger but
they have a lot of the same basic reward
circuitry and what they found was guided
by optogenetics they were able to have a
group of cocaine addicted human beings
no longer seek cocaine they had an
experimental group on a control group
and they had a very powerful effect this
sort of thing shows how far we've come
that we cannot directly affect with that
principle guided approach these very
powerful and important fundamental
behaviors in human beings and this makes
of course coming back to the initial
inspiration that that we had starting to
go down this path now we do understand
in a causal and precise fashion many of
the cells and connections across the
brain that do affect these very
important and both basic and disease
relevant behaviors now this of course
had very humble beginnings if you recall
those those initial tallies in the lab
notebook and we've come a long way since
then but in a way it's even more
striking when you think how how these
very simple organisms themselves have
created these these tools that let us
make this progress there's a whole other
world that has happened as well in terms
of discovering how these basic microbial
opsins work
we've been able to adjust the speed of
the options their sensitivity to light
we've been able to engineer them to
conduct different kinds of ions to turn
cells on or off guided by getting to the
crystal structure of one of these
channelrhodopsins and we can change the
color that they respond to as well this
has allowed us to do something very
important which is to tune the amount
and the timing of the activity that we
play in to precisely what's naturally
occurring and the organism even that
same individual during a very well
defined behavior and so this this
elegance and precision of the method
again is all the more striking when you
think back to how crude and simple some
of the early experiments were and how
long it took to get the whole system
working but in the end that's what makes
a biology fun and beautiful and I hope
to have conveyed some of that to you
today
you